ab dem 19 Dezember bei Phoenix auch
online und in den Mediatheken von ARD
und ZDF
immer am Start Tag und Nacht 227 auf
Knopfdruck weltweit für jeden Geschmack
auf phoenix.de und in den Mediatheken
von ARD und ZDF die Phoenix Dokus im
Netz Doc digital
[Musik]
bündelweise Geld in kleinen Scheinen
gefunden den Tüten und Koffern bei der
Vizepräsidentin des Europäischen
Parlamentes Eva Kylie mutmaßlich gezahlt
von Qatar und Marokko um sich Einfluss
zu verschaffen ein Skandal wie aus einem
schlechten Film der den Ruf aller
Politiker beschädigt als hätte die
Europäische Union nicht genügend Krisen
zu meistern auf dem letzten Gipfel des
Jahres beraten die Staats- und
Regierungschefs heute über Gaspreise und
weitere Folgen des Ukraine Krieges in
den Schlagzeilen da bleibt aber die
Bestechlichkeit im Schatten des
korruptions-skandals EU-Gipfel in
Brüssel unser Thema in der phönix-runde
[Musik]
Phoenix Runde
schönen guten Abend ich begrüße ganz
herzlich aus Berlin darf in meine Gäste
vorstellen bei uns ist Elmar Brook erst
viel zu Präsident der
christlich-demokratischen internationale
er war fast 40 Jahre Mitglied des
Europäischen Parlaments und zuletzt
Vorsitzender des Ausschusses für
auswärtige Angelegenheiten und herzlich
willkommen Funder Tekin Direktorin am
Institut für europäische Politik und
Mitglied des Vorstands der europäischen
Bewegung Deutschland und ich begrüße
Matthias Brückmann international
Korrespondent des Handelsplatz er hat
als korresponden Korrespondent in Moskau
Brüssel und Warschau gearbeitet ist ein
Schwerpunkt ist jetzt die arabische Welt
und zu Katar hatte ein Buch geschrieben
tausend und eine Macht Fußball
Flüssiggas Finanzimperium und herzlich
willkommen Timo lange
Politikwissenschaftler tätig im Berliner
Beruf von lobbyControl zuständig für die
Themen Transparenz und Abgeordneten
Bestechung und wir werden natürlich nach
Brüssel schalten wenn der Gipfel seine
Pressekonferenz hat denn das läuft alles
noch und wir warten da auf die Presse
Konferenz wenn da was passiert
unterbrechen wir unsere Diskussion kurz
Herr Lange schauen wir aber jetzt mal
auf diesen Skandal denn das ist doch das
Thema was alle sehr erschüttert hat dass
da so viel Bargeld gefunden wurde im
Haus der Vizepräsidentin was ist das für
uns Skandal was wissen wir bis jetzt ja
also in der Tat das ist wirklich ein
ganz schwerwiegender Verdacht der hier
im Raum steht die Ermittlungen haben
hier jeden Tag seitdem das letzte Woche
bekannt geworden ist immer neue Details
ins Tageslicht gebracht der Verdacht
besteht im Kern darin dass gegen große
Geldzahlungen politische Gegenleistungen
von Abgeordneten des Europäischen
Parlaments erfolgt sind dass es quasi
die Definition von Korruption und das
hier wirklich so große Mengen Bargeld im
Spiel waren ist an sich schon verdächtig
wenn da solche Geldkoffer in bar
gefunden werden dann stellt sich die
Frage was sollte denn damit geschehen
und das muss jetzt auf jeden Fall alles
sehr lückenlos aufgeklärt werden es ist
war noch nicht ganz klar wer alles genau
beteiligt war der Ehemann von Frau
keilie hat jetzt wohl einen Geständnis
oder ein Teilgeständnis abgelegt und
einen anderen ehemaligen Abgeordneten da
kommen wir vielleicht gleich noch mal
drauf zu sprechen der jetzt eine
Organisation leitet oder geleitet hat
als quasi zentrale Figur dargestellt der
das Geld eingesammelt haben soll von
Katar aber auch von Marokko
um das an andere Abgeordnete zu
verteilen es wurden mehrere Büros
durchsucht von auch von den
Mitarbeitenden von Abgeordneten und das
Parlament hat dann aber auch sehr
schnell reagiert und gesagt Stopp Frau
kaidi kann jetzt keine Vizepräsidentin
mehr sein sie wurde von ihrer Partei
ausgeschlossen die Fraktion der sozial
Demokraten hat auch sofort gesagt dass
geht nicht wir müssen hier Konsequenzen
ziehen und das ist an sich schon mal
erstmal gut dass schnell reagiert wird
klar geht nur Unschuldsvermutung dass
die Ermittlung abgeschlossen sind aber
die Vorwürfe hier sind so schwer dass da
auch eine politische Reaktion direkt
erfolgen musste und das muss jetzt
natürlich weitergehen das muss Folgen
haben auf verschiedenen Ebenen darüber
reden natürlich wenn man darauf
reagieren soll die Parlamentspräsidenten
Roberta Mezzola hat gesagt das ist ein
Angriff auf die europäische Demokratie
Herr Brückmann ist das ein großer
Angriff und welches Interesse her hätte
Katar um so etwas zu tun ist ja jetzt
wegen der Fußball-WM massiv in Kritik
geraten es geht sozusagen darum dass
Image des Landes
reinzuwaschen aber es geht am
handfestliche wirtschaftliche Interessen
Katha Airways hat vor kurzem Ende
letzten Jahres
open sky Abkommen bekommen mit der
Begründung dass Osteuropa besser
angebunden werden müssen an die
internationalen Drehkreuze was
eigentlich logisch ist
und dadurch hat Kata die Möglichkeit
eben viel mehr Ziele in Osteuropa
anzufliegen und viel mehr
Flugverbindungen zu bekommen obwohl
selber ja nur einen Flughafen anzubieten
hat mit Doha
wieder das eine Argument das andere ist
der ganze Bereich flüssiggas ist
natürlich jetzt völlig
durchmischt worden durch den
Angriffskrieg Russlands auf die Ukraine
dass wir dringend Alternativen suchen
und da wird man an Katar nicht
vorbeikommen das ist wird der die bauen
sich gerade zum weltgrößten
flüssiggasexporteur aus die investieren
45 Milliarden
abhängig von denen man muss es ja nicht
noch eine Geldzahlung geben ja aber es
geht natürlich um die Vertragsgestaltung
auch nicht die Europäische Union hat
nach meinem Verständnis aber da wird
vielleicht anders einschätzen da mein
Verständnis einen großen Fehler gemacht
dass sie damals sehr stark darauf
gesetzt haben Langfristverträge aus dem
Markt zu dringend damals ging es gegen
gastron aber die die Versorgung
Sicherheit wird über Spot merkte und
über kurzfrist Verträge nicht zu sichern
sein und Kater hat das Interesse wegen
der enormen Investition Verträge von
mindestens Deutschland ist der gut
gefahren mit 15 Jahren china hat für 27
Jahre abgeschlossen das sind vielleicht
glaube ich interesse marokko ist noch
mal eine ganz andere Situation
ist ja dann doch noch mal ein
Unterschied Herr Brook was wir empfinden
sie das sie waren nur 39 Jahre da im
Parlament als sie das gehört haben einen
Skandal eine Bestechung in diesem Ausmaß
also welches Ausmaß das ist und wie
viele Personen daran Beteiligten wissen
wir noch nicht das kann auch diese
kleinen
panzeri sein mit einer Griechen als
zusätzlichen Teil weil das der die
Lebensgefährtin eines der hauptstritten
ist so weit wie das heute wissen lass
uns noch hoffen dass es so klein sein
wird so wie wir im Bundestag vor zwei
Jahren Geschichte haben die eine gewisse
Vergleichbarkeit hier hat ich glaube
dass dieses nur in den Griff bekommen
kann wenn man
bestimmte zusätzliche Maßnahme greift
die mit auswärtigen Beziehungen und
Kontakten und Abgeordneten im Ausland zu
tun haben darüber können wir sicherlich
gleich im Detail reden zum zweiten muss
man allerdings auch sagen wenn es sich
auf diesen Kreis bezieht
kriminelle Energie gibt es immer da kann
man die besten Regeln machen und wenn
700 Abgeordnete anständige Arbeit machen
sollte man diese anständige Arbeit diese
Leute nicht in Frage stellen und bei
allen Resolution zu Katar in den letzten
Monaten sind diejenigen das Geld
bekommen haben höchst erfolglos gewesen
in die Resolution ist Europäischen
Parlaments waren sehr klar und eindeutig
in diesen Fragen was Menschenrechte
Arbeitsrecht eigentlich und so weiter
das heißt dass viele Geld hat ja da
offensichtlich umsonst ausgegeben wenn
es nur für diese Zwecke war wenn die
Zwecke mit der Verträgen und so weiter
zu tun haben das müsste man untersuchen
ob das erfolgreiche Einflussnahme gab
dass sie erstmal keinen Einfluss gehabt
haben ihrer Meinung nach Frau ticken
wenn man das so hört was bedeutet das
jetzt was für eine Auswirkung hat so
einen Skandal
ja ich glaube ich bin da so ein bisschen
auch bei Herrn Brook weil also erstmal
muss man natürlich ganz grundlegend
sagen
das muss aufgeklärt werden man muss
herausfinden wer tatsächlich daran
beteiligt ist wie viele Personen
beteiligt sind und die müssen natürlich
auch zur Rechenschaft gezogen werden ich
glaube was aber auch wichtig ist ist
eben jetzt nicht alles unter
Generalverdacht zu stellen sondern auf
jeden Fall auch wirklich dann die Person
zu identifizieren die dafür zuständig
sind weil gerade es ist natürlich auch
ein bisschen ein Paradoxon weil das EP
ja nun gerade die Institution in Brüssel
ist die für Werte steht die Einhaltung
der Werte und das auch immer sehr hoch
hält und das ist sehr wichtig diese
Stimme brauchen wir auch aus Brüssel und
er macht haben wollte das Europäische
Parlament hat ja immer gesagt wir
brauchen eigentlich mehr macht genau
deswegen ist es auch wirklich wichtig
dass wir das auch entsprechend
konservieren und eben jetzt nicht
erstmal unterlaufen lassen von einer
hoffentlich kleinen Gruppe wir wissen
noch wie viele davon sind aber ich
glaube schon dass es wichtig ist da
wirklich so ein bisschen zu
differenzieren dann auch noch mal zur
Frage was auch Interessen sind sie
hatten die die wirtschaftlichen
Interessen genannt ich glaube auch dass
das Schengen Schengen Visa Frage eben da
auch noch mit reinspielt und da
natürlich auch darauf geschält wurde
dass oder wenn man da auch vermutet dass
da eben auch Einfluss genommen werden
wir aber noch mal ganz kurz bevor wir
auf diese Sachen auch mal schauen auf
die Regeln sie haben ja eben gesagt der
Brocken dann braucht man hat ja Regel
man braucht da vielleicht stärkere
Regeln welche Regeln hat man eigentlich
also wie geht man um wenn jemand wenn
jemand ein Geschenk bekommt im
Europäischen Parlament lange gibt es da
genug Regeln also ich möchte noch einmal
ganz kurz anknüpfen die Auswirkungen
eines solchen Skandals
das ist natürlich fatal für das
Vertrauen in die europäischen
Institution in Abgeordnete in das
Europäische Parlament insgesamt das ist
Wasser auf die Mühlen von allen EU
Kritikerinnen und Kritiker schon immer
gesagt haben in Brüssel läuft das eh
alles Geld spielt eine große Rolle da
haben wir kein Vertrauen rein und das
das ist wirklich auch die große Gefahr
in der müssen wir etwas entgegensetzen
und da sind wir dann auch bei den Regeln
also wir können dann nicht dabei stehen
bleiben zu sagen naja das war jetzt
vielleicht eine kleine Clique das sind
so Einzelfälle sondern wir müssen
umfassen schauen was können wir und was
müssen wir tun um unsere als Demokratien
Abwehrkräfte gegen
illegale Einflussnahme gegen legitimer
Einflussnahme zu stärken und da sind wir
auch bei den natürlich dann bei den
Regeln für die Abgeordnete kriminelle
Energie kann man dann ja auch da kann
man dann nichts geben wir mit keiner
Regel verhindern können richtig aber man
kann also das wissen wir noch nicht
genau
allen Ebenen schauen wo wird ein Fluss
genommen und wie können wir Korruption
vorbeugen und da ist Transparenz
natürlich ein ganz wichtiges Element und
da haben wir im Europäischen Parlament
schon eine ganze Reihe von Regeln was
die Annahme von Geschenken angeht was
auch berichtet über Reisen angeht was
Lobby treffen angeht das muss alles
öffentlich gemacht oder gemacht werden
genau also einige Abgeordnete müssen
ihre Treffen mit Lobbyisten offenlegen
es müssen auch neben Tätigkeiten
angegeben werden aber da sind große
Lücken und das sind Einfallstore also
Herr Burg hatte gerade Aserbaidschan
angesprochen da lief es ja nicht über
plumpe Geldsäcke sondern
richtig richtig
Konstruktion das Wasser schachtelte für
Konstruktion wie die Geldern eine Firma
ja das ist richtig geflossen sind
Abgeordnete machen Beratungsfirmen und
da haben wir zum Beispiel im
Europäischen Parlament schwache Regeln
die Abgeordneten können dann sagen ja
ich mache nebenbei eine Beratungsfirma
und sag aber gar nicht wenig da berate
und habe verschiedene Kunden viel Geld
und das sind natürlich Einfallstore für
mögliche Einflussnahme die dann auch zur
Korruption werden kann und um dem
vorzubeugen müssen immer Ross und Reiter
müssen die handelnden Akteure klar
benannt werden wenn da Licht drauf
scheint dann unten eine Kultur herrscht
dass wenn man sich nicht an die Regeln
herrscht dass dann auch wirklich hält
das dann auch wirklich Folgen hat das
beugt der Korruption vor das kann
natürlich wie bei allen Straftaten
können die besten Gesetze und Regeln die
an sich nicht verhindern aber es braucht
dann eben auch klare folgen und da haben
wir gerade im Europäischen Parlament
unterbrechen weil wir müssen schauen
weil wir dort auf die Pressekonferenz
nach dem EU-Gipfel sehen
heute beginnt halb elf in Brüssel nach
dem Europäischen Rat und der
Bundeskanzler hat das Wort guten Abend
das war ein ebenso kurzer wie
konstruktive europäischer Rat heute ich
möchte dem tschechischen Ratsvorsitz
unter
für alle ein großes Lob aussprechen und
lassen Sie mich zu Beginn kurz aufzählen
was auf was wir uns allein in den
vergangenen Tagen in Europa verständigt
haben wir haben einen 13 Milliarden
Hilfspaket für die ein 18 Milliarden
Hilfspaket für die Ukraine verabschiedet
uns auf ein neuntes Sanktionspaket gegen
Russland verständigt sind bedeutende
Schritte zur Absicherung der
Rechtsstaatlichkeit überall in Europa
gegangen haben den Erweiterungsprozess
neuen Schwung verliehen inklusive der
Verleihung des Kandidatenstatus für
Bosnien und Herzegowina und wir setzen
einen Herzensprojekt von mir nun final
um in Europa die globale
Mindestbesteuerung für die großen
Unternehmen und in diesem Geister bin
ich sehr Zuversicht wir werden wir uns
am Montag auch auf weitreichende
Schritte im Energiebereich verständigen
ich sage all das um deutlich zu machen
Europa reagiert geschlossen und
kraftvoll auf die aktuellen Krisen der
Welt
zum heutigen Rat im Einzelnen üblich
haben wir uns zu Beginn der Sitzung mit
der Präsidentin des Europäischen
Parlaments ausgetauscht das Gespräch mit
Roberta metzulla stand dieses Mal
natürlich im Zeichen des
korruptionskampfsaals im Europäischen
Parlament dieser Skandal ist eine sehr
ernste Angelegenheit die das Vertrauen
in die Demokratie und den
Parlamentarismus erschüttern kann
deshalb ist es gut dass die belgischen
Behörden in dem Fall gründlich ermitteln
und auch aufklären und ich vertraue
darauf dass die Präsidentin die
Maßnahmen umsetzt diese uns heute im
Kampf gegen Korruption vorgestellt hat
im Zentrum unser Beratung stand einmal
das Meer das Thema Ukraine bei 10 Monate
liegt der russische Überfall auf die
Ukraine jetzt zurück die EU-Staaten
stehen seit Anfang an eng an der Seite
der Ukraine Präsident selenski war heute
wieder zugeschaltet unsere Botschaft an
ihnen bleibt unverändert die Ukraine hat
unsere volle Unterstützung bei der
Verteidigung ihrer Souveränität und ihre
territorialen Integrität die Europäische
Union hat ihre Unterstützung für die von
Präsident selenski beim G20-Gipfel in
Bali vorgestellte Initiative für einen
gerechten Frieden unterstrichen
wir haben noch einmal betont der perfide
russisch die perfide russische Strategie
die ukrainische Infrastruktur zu
zerstören und die Bürgern und Bürger der
brutalen Winterkälte auszusetzen darf
keinen Erfolg haben und sie wird kein
Erfolg haben unsere gemeinsame
Entschlossenheit die Ukraine so lange
wie nötig politisch humanitär finanziell
und auch mit Waffen zu unterstützen ist
ungebrochen
hierzu zählt die Finanzhilfe von 18
Milliarden Euro die wir vereinbart haben
um die ukrainische Staatsfinanzierung im
kommenden Jahr gemeinsam mit unseren
internationalen Partnern sicherzustellen
zudem stellen wir mehr Geld zur
Verfügung um europäische Waffenlieferung
an die Ukraine zu ermöglichen dafür wird
die europäische friedensfazilität um 2
Milliarden Euro aufgestockt das haben
wir heute hier in Brüssel beschlossen
mit dem 9 Sanktionspaket erhöhen wir den
Druck auf die russische Führung weiter
der russische Angriffskrieg hat aber
auch Folgen für Europa insbesondere was
Energiefragen angeht wir diskutieren
seit längerem was wir gegen die hohen
Energiepreise gemeinsam tun können
das Thema ist kompliziert und sehr
technisch es gilt ein Weg zu finden die
hohen Energiepreise zu senken ohne die
Versorgungssicherheit oder die
Finanzstabilität zu gefährden dieses
Ziel haben alle die heute
zusammengekommen sind und so muss es bei
dem was wir
marktkorrekturmechanismus nennen andere
sprechen von gaspreisdeckel darum gehen
Spekulationen zu unterbinden die Preise
ungerechtfertigt in die Höhe treibend
und um abzusichern das ist genau darum
geht muss es klare
Sicherheitsmechanismen geben die einen
preisdeckel dann aussetzen wenn wir in
einem Mitgliedschaft die
Versorgungssicherheit oder Finanzmarkt
Stabilität gefährdet sehen
wir sind auf diesem Weg deutlich
vorangekommen und haben nun die
Energieminister beauftragt am kommenden
Montag die abschließende Verständigung
zu erreichen ich bin sehr zuversichtlich
dass es dann zu einer finalen Einigung
kommt meine vielen Gespräche heute mit
Kolleginnen und Kollegen verstärkt meine
Zuversicht dabei noch die öffentliche
Fokussierung auf die Frage des Deckels
verstellt etwas den Blick dass die
Energieminister am Montag auch
Beschlüsse fassen werden zum gemeinsamen
gasteinkauf zu solidaritätsmechanismen
in Notfällen und zu dringend benötigten
Beschleunigung des Ausbaus erneuerbare
Energien und der energieplätze
wir haben zudem einen ersten Austausch
gehabt über die Frage der Sicherung
unserer Wettbewerbsfähigkeit
gerade vor dem Hintergrund der Maßnahmen
die die US-Regierung beschlossen hat
lassen Sie mich vorwegstellen die Ziele
des Inflation reduction Acts den
Klimaschutz voranzubringen unterstützen
wir ausdrücklich in seiner jetzigen Form
benachteiligt das Gesetz aber wohl
europäische Unternehmen ich habe mich
deshalb sehr dafür eingesetzt dass wir
die Gespräche mit den USA hier zu
intensivieren und uns am Verbesserung
bemühen
und ich bin dabei sehr ziemlich
zuversichtlich dass wir im Wege des
Dialogs mit unseren amerikanischen
Partnern Verbesserungen auch erreichen
können auch Präsident macron berichtete
dass er in seinen Gesprächen Washington
hierfür eine gewisse Offenheit gespürt
hat wichtig ist dass wir in den
Gesprächen mit den USA jetzt sehr
schnell zu konkreten Ergebnissen kommen
zudem habe ich mich dafür eingesetzt
dass die Europäische Kommission die
Auswirkungen des Inflation reduction
Acts auf die einzelnen Sektoren und
Banken genau analysiert damit wir
zielgerichtet reagieren können
gleichzeitig können wir schon jetzt
wichtige Weichen selber stellen zum
Beispiel durch die Vereinfachung des
beihilferechts oder bei der
Beschleunigung von Genehmigung für
Vorhaben von gemeinsamen europäischen
Interesse den sogenannten ICE ich bin
froh dass die kommissionspräsidentin
hier bereit ist unsere Ideen
aufzugreifen
lass mich zum Ende noch auf zwei weitere
Themen kurz eingehen weil die wir heute
gesprochen haben erstens wir haben es
ausdrücklich begrüßt das Bosnien und
Herzegowina den
EU-Kandidatenstatus erreicht hat klar
ist für uns das
Bosnien-Herzegowina vor dem Beginn der
konkreten Verhandlung noch substanzielle
Reformen umsetzen muss die Europäische
Kommission hat hier die 14
kernprioritäten auch klar benannt
zweitens habe ich mich sehr gefreut dass
es uns heute gelungen ist die globale
Mindestbesteuerung für Unternehmen
europäisch verbindlich zu verankern es
hat länger gedauert als gedacht aber am
Ende stand der Konsens
schon als Finanzminister habe ich mich
für diese Vereinbarung eingesetzt und
sie im oecd-rahmen verhandelt deshalb
gestatten Sie mir ein seltenen Moment
der Zufriedenheit das ist ein wichtiger
Schritt für die globale
Steuergerechtigkeit
schönen Dank meine Damen meine Herren
die erste Frage Markus Becker Spiegel
so weit also der Bundeskanzler nach dem
EU-Gipfel ging dann doch etwas schneller
man hatte erst gedacht dass es viel
länger dauert es gab einige Punkte wo
man sich geeinigt hat Herr Brock wenn
man das hier hört es ist ja eine Menge
auf dem auf dem Zettel sozusagen viel zu
Ukraine noch mal einen Sanktionspaket
beschlossen 18 Milliarden Euro Hilfe er
hat aber auch gesagt das Vertrauen ist
erschüttert durch diesen
korruptions-skandal wie handlungsfähig
und wie stark empfinden sie die EU
gerade auch nach so einem Gipfel wo er
auch klar gemacht wird das was in den
USA gerade passiert ist schwierig und da
muss die EU eben auch sich stark zeigen
also wenn die EU sich vor einem Jahr so
stark gezeigt hätte wie sie sich jetzt
zeigt hätte man vielleicht sogar den
ukraine-krieg verhindern können weil das
die richtige Botschaft an Putin gewesen
wäre
und dass man die Sanktionen gemacht hat
dass man zwar die Hilfe für die Ukraine
macht noch mal die 18 Milliarden
monatlich 1,5 Milliarden damit die
haushaltsmäßig durch die Krise kommen
Maßnahmen um gegen die Kälte vorgehen zu
können die militärische Hilfe wo ich
Kritik habe an dem Maß an dem sich
Deutschland beteiligt aber nicht das
insgesamt der Westen ihr zusammen steht
mit bestimmten Ausnahmen wir unseren
auch in dieser Frage das finde ich schon
ganz toll und dass man sich jetzt bei
diesem Paket dieser Steuern sich
geeinigt hat umso mehr aber es zeigt
auch Schwachpunkte wir brauchen noch
mehr Handlungsfähigkeit
Handlungsfähigkeit die jetzt in Stunde
den Drucks da ist das heißt wir brauchen
eine außen und Sicherheitspolitik aber
auch bestimmten in Markt relevanten
Steuern mehr als Entscheidung innerhalb
Europäischen Union um solchen
Unternehmen im gegentreten zu können und
Steuerschlupflöcher zu löschen
zu schließen und das zeigt die
Europäische Union hat den Willen und die
Kraft wir sollten ja aber auch die
besseren Mechanismen geben das bessere
Handwerkszeug damit dieser Wille
schneller und besser umgesetzt werden
kann Herr Brückmann wir haben sie es
jetzt empfunden ist das ein Punkt gerade
auch diese Finanzsteuer wo er sagt wo
der Bundeskanzler sagt als
Finanzminister wollte er das immer das
eben große Unternehmen jetzt 15 %
mindestens Steuern zahlen müssen das war
glaube ich ähm ein herzliches Anliegen
von Scholz da ist ja seit Jahren mit
unterwegs gewesen und dass die EU das
jetzt beschlossen hat ist sicherlich
wichtig und richtig ich glaube nur noch
nicht dass das die Lösung ist weil sich
einige Staaten sich dem entziehen werden
also gucken wir mal wir haben eben über
Kata gesprochen es gibt noch viel
nettere Länder in der in der Region und
Dubai ist Moment sehr massiv dabei
Unternehmen anzulocken und die denken
gar nicht daran über mindest Steuern zu
reden sie erhöhen zwar jetzt eigene
steuern sie führen dass das erste der
Einkommensteuer ein weil es ihnen
finanziell trotz des gigantischen
ölregens nicht so gut geht nur die
werden Teufel tun im Moment sich darauf
einzulassen Mindestbesteuerung zu machen
also da ist noch glaube ich eine Menge
zu tun und gerade die Länder die im
Moment dabei sind unser
Werte und auch Weltsystem zu untergraben
die müssen viel stärker noch unter Druck
gesetzt werden
da meine ich unter anderem die
Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate mit
die sehr massiv Unternehmen anwerben die
sehr massiv auch ein Konkurrenz gehen
zur europäischen Industrie das ist alles
legitim und in Ordnung nur wir brauchen
halt ein ein Spielfeld auf dem die
gleichen Regeln herrschen unter anderem
eben 15% Mindeststeuer
die EU hat sich jetzt einig gezeigt
heute Frau Tekin wir hatten ja vorher
immer die Auseinandersetzung mit Ungarn
jetzt heute gab es Widerstände von Polen
dass sie erstmal Sachen nicht mittragen
wollen wie positiv ist das jetzt das ist
doch zum Beispiel diese 18 Milliarden
Hilfe dass man sich da geeinigt hat das
ist natürlich erstmal sehr positiv und
ich glaube das zeigt auch dass die EU
eben dann doch fähig ist bestimmte
Paketlösungen zu schnüren die es dann
doch möglich machen zu bestimmten
Entscheidungen zu kommen gleichzeitig
darf man nicht vergessen und das hat das
jetzt ganz klar gezeigt dass in dieser
Solidarität auch immer so ein bisschen
Sand im Getriebe drin ist was man nicht
aus den Augen lassen kann und ihm Ungarn
hat erst die Mindeststeuer blockiert um
eben zu verhindern das Geld eingefroren
werden jetzt waren es Polen und man muss
es letztendlich immer wieder im Blick
haben dass man eben dann im Zweifel dann
paketisch nehmen muss um zu Solidarität
dann auch zu kommen aber dass das jetzt
geklappt hat und das Polen dann doch
auch wieder weiter zurückgegangen ist
und dem zugestimmt hat zeigt dann doch
dass das dann die Solidarität zumindest
auch gegenüber der Ukraine vielleicht
wenn man es dann so ausdrücken auch auch
gegeben ist aber es bleibt eine
Herausforderung und ich glaube hier ist
natürlich auch die einstimmigkeits
Erfordernis ist da natürlich auch wieder
eine Herausforderung die für solche
solidaritätsfragen dann entsprechend
auch
schwierig sind und eine andere Sache die
jetzt glaube ich noch nicht genannt
wurde was ich aber auch sehr wichtig
finde ist dass jetzt schon für auf die
Agenda für für den nächsten Rat die
Migrationsthematik auf den auf der
Agenda gesetzt wurde auch da ist
Solidarität gefragt
Berlin aber natürlich dieses wird
gezeigt dass ein kleines Land wie die
Tschechische Republik
großartige Präsidentschaft lassen kann
die haben das im Wesen ausgegangen die
haben Pakete geschnürt
wir Deutschen sollten nicht immer so
hochnäsig auf die kleinen gucken Prag
hat dann dollenjob gemacht okay also sie
sagen dass wäre wichtig oder man müsste
die kleineren Länder da stärker
mitnehmen das war ja auch was was also
die Leistung anerkennen die machen es
ohne uns wir haben easy eher behindert
im letzten halben Jahr also dass wir ihn
geholfen haben
ich würde gerne mal auf Ungarn schauen
weil das natürlich auch jetzt in diesem
Thema des korrosionskandals nochmal ein
Thema war Katharina barley die
stellvertretende Parlamentspräsidentin
hat gesagt das Parlament hat bewiesen
wie man mit korruptionsvorfällen in den
eigenen Reihen umgehen muss so muss es
in Demokratien sein da wird man wegen
Korruption aus Ämtern entfernt
strafrechtlich verfolgt in Ungarn wird
der korrupteste Ministerpräsident was
bedeutet dieser Skandal für Ungarn
ja das ist natürlich dieser Skandal sehr
bitter für die europäische Demokratie
die europäischen Werte
Rechtsstaatlichkeit Demokratie die auch
gerade ja nach außen aber auch nach
innen Polen Ungarn verteidigt werden
müssen wir haben jetzt in Brüssel viele
viele Jahre darüber diskutiert das muss
doch Folgen haben wenn Mitgliedsstaaten
der EU
Standards verletzten wenn wenn das nicht
mit ja demokratischen Dingen dort zugeht
das muss da musste ihn EU darauf
antworten und gerade jetzt im zeitlichen
Zusammenhang mit diesem Skandal ist es
ja erstmalig dazu gekommen dass Ungarn
Gelder in gefroren wurden in relevanter
Höhe und Herrmann hat sich ja wenig
überraschend hat heute oder gestern auf
twittern Foto von diesen Bargeld bündeln
gepostet und darüber geschrieben ja so
sieht also europäische
Rechtsstaatlichkeit aus also verhöhnend
sich darüber lustig gemacht
und trotzdem bleibt die EU
handlungsfähig und man darf nicht den
Fehler machen jetzt die gesamte Arbeit
des Parlamentes das wirklich sich in den
vergangenen Jahren sehr massiv für die
Demokratie eingesetzt hat auch für
Transparenz und stärkere Kontrolle von
Lobbyismus und Korruption immer dafür
geworben hat auch den anderen
EU-Institutionen gegenüber diese Arbeit
zu diskreditieren aber es ist ein
bisschen eine Steilvorlage
genau das Wort was ihm im Kopf hatte das
ist natürlich eine Steilvorlage was dann
auch natürlich von Orban erstmal
ausgeschlachtet wird nichtsdestotrotz
muss man ja nicht ins gleiche Horn
schlagen glaube ich sondern ich finde
man nur schon gucken dass ähm das habe
ich eben vorhin auch noch mal gesagt
dass man eben jetzt nicht den
Generalverdacht ausspricht sondern da
jetzt entsprechend ihre Formen macht und
damit umgeht und das IP macht ist damit
entsprechend umgegangen die ist keine
Vizepräsidentin mehr und das muss man
dann eben dann so auch sehen aber ich
glaube es ist eine sehr schwierige
Kommunikationsaufgabe auch weil ich
nämlich auch ihre Meinung teile dass das
natürlich auch ein Vertrauensverlust
gerade auch in der Bevölkerung in der in
den europäischen Mitgliedstaaten
bedeuten kann und wenn man dann jetzt
sogar ein Jahr weiter guckt und 2024
kommen die die Wahlen fürs Europäische
Parlament und die sind wichtig und bis
dahin muss man wirklich dann auch diesen
Vertrauensverlust sollte der tatsächlich
sich manifestieren auch wieder
ausgeräumt haben
ein gutes Zeichen dass die Europäische
Union vor diesen Korruptions Skandal
gegen Ungarn vorgegangen ist und
übrigens ja nicht nur gegen Ungarn aber
das polnische Geld ist ja de facto
eingefroren es gibt zwar noch keinen
Entscheidungen aber so lange ist das
Geld eingefroren und diese Dinge finden
halt statt wobei das eben eine andere
Ebene ist ja das macht der Europäische
Rat und wir reden jetzt irgendwie diesen
Korruptions Skandal über das Europäische
Parlament und da muss man natürlich noch
mal genauer hingucken ich glaube
überhaupt nicht dass das jetzt allein
Cutter und Marokko waren ja ich meine
ich darf noch mal darauf hinweisen dass
als die die Nachbarstaaten eine Blockade
gegen Katha verhängt haben 2017 wurden
Milliarden in die Hand genommen um
Lobbyismus in Washington und sonst wo zu
betreiben da ist sehr schnell sehr viel
Geld unterwegs und ich glaube überhaupt
nicht dass das Ausmaß da es würde mich
sehr wundern ich will es mal so
umformulieren
von der Linken der sagt auch das ist
jetzt eigentlich nur die oder ist die
Spitze des Eisberg
auf der anderen Seite her sie kennen das
aus ihrer damaligen Fraktion wie viel
Kasachstan und äh also auf dem Tisch
gelegt haben also dagegen sind ganz
andere so ein Bundestag in Europa
hat und da waren auch deutsche
Bundestagsabgeordnete betroffen aber
auch Italiener in italienischer
Abgeordneter geboren wurde
und ja wir müssen diesen Fall zum
Anlassen nehmen das ist eine Spitze das
Eis schwierigeres würde ich auch sagen
besonders extremer Aussicht ja natürlich
ganz gut ein besonders extrem ein
besonders extremer Auswuchs den wir zum
Anlass nehmen sollten über
Einflussstrategien anderer Staaten
insbesondere autoritärer Regierungen zu
sprechen die mit teilweise sehr legalen
und transparenten Mitteln stattfinden
das ist auch völlig in Ordnung dass da
treffen
wie funktioniert das wenn man im
Europäischen Parlament ist wie sehr sind
sie in ihrer Zeit wie viele Leute sind
auf die zugekommen haben gesagt ich gebe
Ihnen ein bisschen Geld damit sie
bestimmte Entscheidungen treffen
hoffentlich ist keiner zugekommen der
mir Geld angeboten hat in einem Fall
hatte sich angedeutet das war sehr
schade dann aber kein Treffen
stattgefunden deswegen konnte man nicht
anbieten
Gespräch mit dem Staatspräsidenten
na was wir machen müssen ist
in solchen Fällen also einmal nicht
allgemein Verdacht und wenn Orban Stall
Pass schickt muss man auch nicht
hinterherlaufen dann ist es ein Fehlpass
und wenn ich Kommentare sehe die schon
am Montag wussten was alles da passiert
ist mit generellem Urteil das
Europäische Parlament kein Anspruch hat
über Menschenrechtsfragen in der
nächsten Zeit zu entscheiden dann muss
ich mich auch mit solchen Kommentatoren
auseinandersetzen
ich bin da Auffassung dass wir die guten
Maßnahmen die man ergriffen hat beim
Gesetzgebungsverfahren man muss angeben
wenn man mit einem Lobbyisten spricht
und so weiter jedenfalls die
berichterstatte die
Ausschussvorsitzender zu alter das muss
man auch in die Außenbeziehungen
hineinsetzen
man muss mitteilen mit welchen wenn man
redet man muss mitteilen von wem man
eingeladen ist man muss mitteilen Werft
welche Flugkosten bezahlt hat
welcher Staat welche Stiftung wir müssen
sehen dass in diesem Fall ist ein
banziris der ihr
Menschenrechtsorganisation gegründet hat
die großen Krankheiten wo große Leute
sitzen gerade umgewählt haben aber in
Wirklichkeit das Geld
abwicklungsmaschinen gewesen sind
deswegen müssen injus untersucht werden
es gibt keinen bösen und guten
Lobbyismus es ist alles Lobbyismus und
deswegen müssen deswegen müssen genauso
transparent sein wie das Unternehmen ist
in der gleichen Art und Weise und im
inneren und äußeren aber im äußeren
insgesamt was die Verfahren angeht zum
wie man für welchen Zweck eingeladen ist
und wer das bezahlt wenn man sieht
beispielsweise AFD Leute hier oder auch
leben Leute aus dem Europäischen
Parlament und ich habe ja meine
Ausschussvorsitzende Zeit das
mitbekommen die dann auf russische
Kosten zur Wahl beobachten auf die
Krämpfe fahren und so weiter das haben
die ja nicht selbst bezahlt Maßnahmen
die Leben beispielsweise die Kredite von
Putin bekommen hat für Wahlkämpfe das
muss aufgelegt werden wir müssen mal
feststellen was gelaufen ist was das ist
Transparenz das muss alles transparent
sein man muss die Möglichkeiten einenken
ich glaube dass es im auswärtigen
Beziehungen noch leichter ist gilt
reinzuschieben als es bei der schon
erfeuchten
transparenzmaßnahmen die heute
vorgeschrieben sind im Bundestag im
Europäische Parlament die ist vor zehn
Jahren noch nicht gab da ist
Verbesserung vorhanden aber die
Verbesserung ist noch nicht da in den
Außenbeziehungen und da muss man
entsprechend in einem letzter Punkt noch
jeder jeder jeder
Botschafter meint er müsste eine
freundschaftsgruppe im europäischen
parlamentgrund die müssen generell
verboten werden
diese freundschaftsgruppen es gibt eine
katarische freundschaftsgruppe mit zehn
Mitgliedern habe ich mir sagen lassen
und das sind natürlich
zu Hause nachweisen ich habe da Einfluss
organisiert okay das muss Behörden das
darf nicht erlaubt sein
ich glaube das ist sogar auch von dem
Teil des 10 punkteplans was mit sola
jetzt eben auch vorgeschlagen hat genau
solche Gruppen eben auch zu unterbinden
ich glaube es ist wirklich in der Tat
also Transparenz ist wichtig weil ich
finde wenn man auch so ein bisschen
zwischen Korruption und Lobbyismus dann
eben auch noch mal unterscheidet ich
glaube schon dass natürlich der
Austausch gerade auch mit mit Think
Tanks oder anderen Gruppierungen oder
NGOs auch wirklich wichtig ist das
gehört sondern Demokratie auch dazu
wichtig ist aber natürlich das genau
dann entsprechend Transparenz zu machen
und wenn ich jetzt weiß dass ich als
Vertreterin des Instituts für
europäische Politik im
Transparenzregister stehen hier im
Lobbyregister stehen wenn ich in den
Bundestag gehe wird das entsprechend
eben auch nachgehalten das ist sehr
aufwendig war früher anders und dann
fragt man sich natürlich auch was ist
dann schon Lobbyismus und was ist was
ist dann tatsächlich einfach nur eine
Diskussion aber genau solche Regeln
führen ja dazu dass man genau einfach
transparent damit umgeht mit wem habe
ich geredet
wo ich hole ich mir vielleicht auch
meine Ideen her und solange dann keine
Gelder dazu fließen ist das dann
letztendlich auch alles entsprechend
weil ich meine es werden doch gerade von
den für den mittelosteuropäischen
Staaten werden sind doch in letzter Zeit
unglaublich viele Ding Tanks gegründet
worden die für nichts anderes da sind
als diesen politischen Lobbyismus zu
betreiben und zwar wird dann immer auch
noch mal entweder
Beispiel Karl-Heinz Rummenigge noch mal
eine Uhr rüber gereicht oder eben auch
Geld und ich meine und dann muss man
vielleicht auch die Gegenseite noch mal
sehen es gibt die einen die das Geld
geben ja die haben sie beim deutschen
Zoll erwischt er selber hätte das nicht
angegeben aber
ich meine das eine ist sind die Länder
die Geld geben und das andere sind die
diese annehmen also das Schlimme ist
dass die die Käuflichkeit in der Politik
leider zugenommen hat ist mein Eindruck
ja das irgendwie immer mehr solche
Organisationen gegründet werden und das
als immer selbstverständlicher gilt ähm
ich Einladungen oder sowas zu bekommen
die sind so die sind Punkte die sind so
entschieden worden weil Menschen
das ist extrem schwer danach zuweisen
wie gesagt wir haben schon über
kasachstante geredet wir haben über
Aserbaidschan geredet die haben das ja
nicht gemacht weil sie in der Meinung
waren sie wollen jetzt mal wichtig
werden
das ist eine gute Frage hat hat immerhin
in der Europameisterschaft austragen
dürfen und sowas ich meine wenn die
gleichen oder wenn die gleiche
selbst eine Resolution im Europarat die
dann durchgefallen ist da ging es darum
politische Gefangene die Situation
politischer Gefangene in Aserbaidschan
zu verurteilen und dann war man völlig
überrascht als das plötzlich keine
Mehrheit bekommen hat und erst
jahrelange Ermittlungsarbeit hat dann
offen gelegt dass eine ganze Reihe der
Abgeordneten die das verhindert haben
auf dem einen oder anderen Weg Geld aus
Aserbaidschan bekommen haben und wenn
sie vorhin gesagt haben Transparenz ist
wichtig ja wir haben das äh
Transparenzregister in Brüssel wir haben
zwischen Amerika gestern in Deutschland
aber wenn man da jetzt mal schaut nach
Katar taucht da eigentlich nicht auf
also in Brüssel nicht in Deutschland
können wir vielleicht kurz noch mal
drüber reden taucht auf teilweise aber
und auch diese Organisation dieser
Organisation von von von Siri steht da
gar nicht drin obwohl dir das habe ich
gerade heute noch mal nachgeguckt im
Juni im Europäischen Parlament in der
Bibliothek in Veranstaltung gemacht
haben mit Abgeordneten also ganz aktiv
dann natürlich auch waren und das heißt
hier fehlt es an der ordentlichen
Kontrolle und Durchsetzung dieser
Transparenzregeln die man eigentlich hat
das wird weder bei den Lobbyisten
vernünftig kontrolliert noch bei den
Abgeordneten der vertraut man einfach
viel zu sehr darauf dass die das alles
schon richtig und vollumfänglich
anfangen von Katar ist das jetzt aber
sozusagen wirklich nach hinten
losgegangen weil eigentlich gab es schon
Erleichterungen für Katar für die für
Visa Erleichterung und die sind jetzt
ausgesetzt also das hat sich dann nicht
gelohnt ist das schreckt das andere
Länder wirklich ab
ich war ehrlich gesagt bei Katar Visa
Erleichterung finde ich die ganze
Diskussion albern es gibt keinen
einzigen katarischen Asylbewerber
bei den bei dem bei denen Einnahmen die
die katarischen Menschen haben
das glaube ich nicht wirklich Thema
Haushalten
gibt es keinen Migrationsdruck dort gibt
es keine so müssen wir uns wirklich
keine Sorgen machen
ja wieder zurück ist natürlich was
anderes darüber gucken wir natürlich
noch nicht so richtig rein ja Marokko
hatten wir handfeste
Diskussionen in den letzten Wochen und
Monaten da ist natürlich die Situation
völlig anderes ja sie waren sie waren
europaauftragter des Vorstands der
Bertels Mann AG und haben auch das
Brüsseler lobbybüro von geleitet wenn
ich richtig informiert bin wie hat man
wie haben sie das denn zusammen war das
nicht wahr ich war viel zu Puzzle Media
development und habe das Büro nicht
geleitet okay das waren okay dann haben
wir das klargestellt
ich habe eine bezahlte transparente
öffentlich angegebene eingetragen im
Tätigkeit als Berater haben sie da nein
ich war eingestellt oder angestellt und
Angestellter mit
Arbeitslosenversicherung auch wenn Sie
heute noch mal drauf gucken würden sie
doch wahrscheinlich auch sagen dass das
nicht ganz so klug ist sowas und
weiterhin zu betreiben dieses ist
weiterhin so dass Abgeordnete auch Namen
oder des Bundesverfassungsgericht werden
Beruf ausüben dürfen
das ist ja das eine aber die Frage ist
trotzdem was hat sich geändert in den
Jahren die sie waren 39 Jahre im
Europaparlament wenn sie jetzt heute
noch mal ins Europaparlament gehen wann
würden Sie sagen bestimmte Dinge würde
ich heute vielleicht dann anders machen
müsste man könnte man nein ich habe da
nichts vorzugreifen ich bin
niemals erstmal ist das nicht das Thema
was jetzt anstehen was dann steht
erstens bin ich ein aus allen
Ausschüssen herausgegangen die mit
Medienpolitik und die mit
unternehmerischen Interessen zu tun
haben ich habe nie dazu geredet und
einmal habe ich dazu geredet da habe ich
einen Plenum erklärt an die Klammer
interest wie man das in England macht
insofern ist das so okay gewesen
natürlich verändern sich Vorstellungen
was man machen kann und was man nicht
machen kann aber jedenfalls halte ich es
für richtig dass Abgeordnete auch
beruflich tätig sein können und zwar
nicht nur Rechtsanwälte
Umgang mit Interessenkonflikten gibt
also auch gerade angedeutet dass sie
dann nicht in den entsprechenden
Ausschüssen tätig waren weil
Interessenkonflikt davor liegt und
verfassungsausschüsse gewesen Punkt
Interessenkonflikt sehen zu können muss
man erstmal sehen was ist denn die
Nebentätigkeit und wenn da jemand eben
als Berater oder in einer anderen
Funktion etwas nicht richtig angeht oder
gar
nicht veröffentlicht worden und ins
Register des Parlaments eingetragen
worden und zwar auch im elektronischen
was nicht vorgeschrieben war aber zum
Glaubwürdigkeit von Parlamenten oder
manchmal ausdrücklich den Bundestag und
das Europäische Parlament gehört doch
dass die Abgeordneten sich voll ihre
gesetzgeberischen Tätigkeit widmen und
ich noch nebenbei deswegen
sie sehen welche Abgeordneten was wie
viele Arbeiter haben das mir
beispielsweise jemand vorgeworfen hätte
dass ich nicht genug gearbeitet hätte
den Parlament den persönlich nicht nur
das ist doch ein ein wie erklären sie
den Menschen die an die wahloren gerufen
werden dass sie dort Leute wählen die
offenbar so viel Zeit haben dass sie
nebenbei noch ganz andere Sachen haben
gucken sich mal die Fehlzeiten im
Deutschen Bundestag haben das ist doch
furchtbar okay aber das ist jetzt um die
Frage wie wie kriegt man das Vertrauen
jetzt wieder hin und die ist ja auch die
Frage Frauen haben den einzelne
Parlamentarier eigentlich so viel Macht
dass sie wenn sie Geld annehmen wirklich
Entscheidungen beeinflussen kann
ja ich glaube also erstmal ist glaube
ich auch das was Sie gesagt haben ganz
ganz deutlich geworden und auch hier aus
der Diskussion es gibt ja schon eine
ganze Reihe der Regel in sie müssen nur
tatsächlich auch eingehalten werden und
dann braucht sie Kontrollmechanismen um
Halt zu überprüfen ob die Leute das
entsprechend einhalten oder nicht und
ich glaube das ist etwas wo man sich
jetzt im Europäischen Parlament
wahrscheinlich dann auch noch mal die
Gedanken machen muss also erstmal die
Regeln überprüfen und dann eben zu
gucken wie wie kann man das Ganze eben
dann auch ähm kontrollieren und und
einfordern
es ist also kein Parlamentarier kann
alleine was entscheiden letztendlich ne
das heißt wenn wenn er beeinflusst wurde
kann natürlich in Debatten der Ton
gesetzt werden wie Frau Kelly das
gemacht hat in der in der Katar
Geschichte dennoch gab es ja die
Resolution des Europäischen Parlaments
genau eben zu dem der
Menschenrechtsfrage gegen Katar das
heißt da war die Einflussnahme dann ja
gar nicht so groß in dem Sinne oder die
Einfluss sind sie
den sie da hatte es ist dann natürlich
die Frage wie viele und welche Netzwerke
haben sie und in welchen Ausschüssen
sitzen sie glaube ich um dann halt zu
gucken wie wieder Einfluss ist aber
jetzt sind wir wieder bei der Sache
vereinzelte Personen haben eben weniger
Einfluss als als dann mehrere Gruppen
sagen also Europäischen Parlament schon
eine Besonderheit ist im Vergleich auch
zum Bundestag das dann einzelne
Abgeordnete Änderungsanträge einbringen
können auch zu Themen für die sie
eigentlich gar nicht zuständig sind und
auch da hatten wir schon Skandale in der
Vergangenheit das hieß damals dann cash
for love_lo
das passiert ist also das kommt kommt
schon vor und bedeutet nur man muss dann
noch genauer hinschauen und man sollte
nicht verbieten ja ja
einzelne Abgeordneten im Europäischen
Parlament hat sehr viel mehr
Möglichkeiten
stehen Abgeordneten ja und das möchte
ich bitte nicht beseitigt wissen die
Einzelanträge kann ja nur auf der
ausschussebene Stellen nicht im Plenum
also das ist wenn es wirklich ans
Eingemachte geht kann er mit kann
einzelner kein Antrag mehr stellen
sondern dann muss man fraktionsgröße
haben also die Mindestgröße haben als
Gruppenantrag oder was auch immer das
ist schon Vorsorge dafür getrieben dass
ich ja nicht plötzlich Entscheidung der
Gesetzgebung beeinflussen können aber
das Europäische Parlament ist deswegen
so spannend weil wir hier nicht Jungs
werden Opposition aufgeteilt sind da und
von daher der einzelne Abgeordnete mehr
bewegen kann aber es muss eben unter
dieser Kontrolle anfälliger oder ist man
deshalb leichter Beute von ähm man
könnte vielleicht interessanter sein
aber ich habe den Eindruck auch das
Botschaften oder andere die versuchen
sowas zu engagieren nachweisen wollen
gegenüber ihrem Arbeitgebern was ihnen
alles Wege bringen und dass sie
bestimmte Leute den anderen Stellen
etwas bewegen das ist dann muss man
sagen
fehlgelaufenes Geld das Gehen hinterher
bestehen will wie kann man sich
sozusagen ja resilient heißt es jetzt
immer so schön der Brückmann die kann
man sich stärken als als Politiker dass
man dafür nicht
ja dass man da nicht in Gefahr kommt
das eine und das andere ist eben
öffentlich zu machen wie viel Geld man
von wem bekommt oder die Frage andersrum
wie sind denn die Methoden Merkmale
schnell genug um was es da wirklich geht
ist das immer so eine direkte Ansprache
oder ist es eine andere Art ein bisschen
raffinierter dass sie erstmal mit
anderen Sachen kommen oder sowas und
es ist ja auch nicht nur das Europäische
Parlament gucken sich mal an wie viele
komische freundschaftsvereine ist in in
Deutschland gibt die deutsche
aserbaidschanische Gesellschaft war
dafür berühmt ja die Verstorbene
Vorsitzende
redet ja nicht schlecht über Tote aber
ich meine ich saß daneben als sie Toast
ausgebracht hat auf Diktator und ihm ein
langes Leben und eine kräftige Hand
gewünscht hat wo ich gedacht habe
merkwürdige
heilspredigen für für einen Diktator
aber das ist halt auch Teil der Teil der
Realität und und man muss man nachdenken
wie wir solche die fahren irgendwie in
der parlamentarischen Gesellschaft statt
ja also das sind alles natürlich Dinge
wo man drüber nachdenken kann ob wir ob
wir solche Orte solchen Vereinen zur
Verfügung stellen und ob wir diese
Vereine eigentlich so wollen und wollen
die suchen sich ja ganz bewusst auch
Bundestagsabgeordnete die dort
Vorsitzende werden gucken sich mal diese
ganzen Lobbygruppen an ja
interessanterweise viele ihrer Partei
und der fdpd
sehr viel weniger interessant also diese
Partei Zuordnung ist schwer verständlich
wenn ich die diese Reinfällen auf enjoos
sehen da ist sind die ist auf der linken
Seite sind sie da verdammt gut muss ich
sagen nach meinem Verständnis was ich so
mitgekriegt habe deutlich weniger
anderthalb Millionen waren jetzt glaube
ich nicht gern primären Abgeordnete
gerichtet oder habe ich das falsch
gucken was dabei rauskommt ich glaube
ich glaube nicht dass die nur
Unterschied sehen Sie der Unterschiede
also in
Parteizugehörigkeit Eva Kylie gehört
jetzt immer Sozialistin also man sollte
das auf jeden Fall nicht parteipolitisch
ausschlachten das hat auch Manfred Weber
gesagt relativ kurz nachdem das ganze
Teil bekannt wurde
jetzt heute in den letzten Tagen hat
sich dann die die EVP also die
Sozialdemokratie Christdemokraten im
Parlament dann doch irgendwie
entschieden dass jetzt zu versuchen den
sozial Demokraten vor allem an zu lassen
das ist wirklich so ein bisschen man
muss aufpassen mit den Steinen zu werfen
wenn man doch auch eine eigene
Geschichte von verschiedenen Skandalen
und Verstrickungen in dem Bereich hat
also das ist nicht zielführend und das
behebt auch den Schaden an das dann
Vertrauen nicht ähm ich wollte nur wäre
richtig gewesen und es wäre jetzt auch
nicht im Bundestag
Fraktion viel zu lange immer gesagt ach
Unschuldsvermutung wir schließen dann
niemanden aus wir bewegen auch niemand
zum Rücktritt und Frau strenz um die ist
da ganz zentral ging das dann verstorben
plötzlich so die Ermittlungen waren noch
gar nicht abgeschlossen aber sie war
immer noch im Bundestag ganz normal mit
dabei und ja wir müssen auch schauen
ehemalige Abgeordnete sehen wir jetzt ja
hier wieder mit Herrn pensiri aber auch
im Bundestag deutsche parlamentarische
Gesellschaft man hat sehr viele
Privilegien als ehemaliger Abgeordneter
hat Zugang hat Netzwerk und wenn man
dann die Seiten wechselt glaube ich ist
wird behält man die lebenslang das ist
im EP genauso wie im Bundestag und das
müssen wir eigentlich hinterfragen weil
da ist ist man dann besonders anfällig
oder offensichtlich sind viele ehemalige
besonders anfällig dann sich vor
bestimmte Interessen okay
oder von alleine die schlägt ein
Ethikrat vor für EU-Institutionen ist
das wenn man hätte vielleicht gedacht
vielleicht gibt's das sowas schon aber
gibt es noch nicht also ist das sinnvoll
wie könnte sowas aussehen na also ich
glaube das ist auf jeden Fall erstmal
eine sinnvolle Idee um da zumindestens
das was ich vorhin auch gesagt habe eben
dann auch noch mal zu prüfen ob die
Regeln die eben dann entsprechend
aufgestellt werden auch eingehalten
werden und ich glaube wie so was konkret
aussehen kann da müsste man noch mal
noch mal drüber nachdenken aber erstmal
ist das etwas wo ich sage das ist
zumindest etwas wo man dann auch einen
Namen draufsetzen kann und jetzt sind
wir wieder beim Vertrauen und das kann
dann im Zweifel auch wieder Vertrauen
auch dann noch mal schüren würden Sie
denn sagen das sind bei den 27
Mitgliedstaaten dass man da auf einen
Nenner kommt was ethische Standards in
Bezug auf beschäftlichkeit betrifft naja
wir haben natürlich die Grundwerte die
auch in Artikel 2 eu-v sozusagen
festgeschrieben sind und ich glaube
schon dass man dazu mindestens einen
Grundwerte Katalog dann doch auch
aufstellen könnten können muss um
sozusagen dann zumindestens das Raster
zu haben mit Ungarn Polen ist es
wahrscheinlich
könnte das Parlament ohne Mitsprache der
Mitgliedstaaten für hier einrichten
könnten Kommission und Parlament
zusammen machen wenn der Radler jetzt
nicht mitziehen will
das auch getrennt machen ich würde da
nicht Exekutive und Parlament
miteinander vermischen das will ich
getrennt machen und wie möchte ich
könnte dann so ein Rad sein das ist ja
dann immer die Frage ist doch immer wenn
es kriminell ist wie kriegt man es raus
das ist der Punkt und deswegen ist die
Frage ist auch die Frage von
Unabhängigkeit
Abgeordneten haben traditionellen
Immunität damit
Staaten nicht auf sie einwirken können
regierende nicht auf sie einwirken
können dass der Klasse die Grund für
Immunität dass sie nicht unter Druck
gesetzt werden
und ich finde das man da genau aufpassen
müsste man parlamentarische Rechte
Unabhängigkeit des Parlament ist nicht
dabei zerstört aber ich finde das
Parlament hat hier sehr schnell reagiert
für meine Gesicht überraschend schnell
reagiert und da müssen gute Vorarbeit
zusammen mit Frau mit Solar gelaufen
sein
das OLAF und die Polizei Olaf ist die
betroffene Behörde doch das oder der
Europäischen Union und die Polizei
direkten Zugang zu Büros von
Abgeordneten und Mitarbeiter im
Parlament hatte das dauert üblicherweise
Wochen und Monate bis das möglich ist
unterscheiden das scheint also von der
Ferne betrachtet verdammt gut gelaufen
zusammen und die Parlamentspräsidentin
gemacht das ist es soll nicht unter den
Teppich gekehrt werden es ist nicht
Business asusche vielen Dank für die
Diskussion von Theken Herr Lange Herr
Brock und der Brückmann vielen dank
ihnen fürs zuschauen das war die letzte
Phoenix Runde in diesem Jahr aber wenn
sie Sehnsucht haben kein Problem bei uns
gibt's in der Mediathek bei der ARD
Mediathek und bei Phoenix finden Sie
auch ganz viele Runden die Sie
vielleicht verpasst haben zu vielen
spannenden Themen also wir freuen uns
wenn Sie reinschauen und wir freuen uns
natürlich wenn sie wieder dabei sind am
10 januar sind wir wieder für Sie da und
wir das sind nicht nur wir hier vor der
Kamera sondern das sind auch die in
Regie Technik Produktion und Redaktion
die man immer nicht sieht über die ganz
viel dazu beitragen dass das eine gute
Phönix Runde wird und bei denen würde
ich mich gerne einmal bedanken im Namen
des ganzen Teams die Leisten nämlich
auch großartige Arbeit und Ihnen als
Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer wünsche ich
einfach eine schöne gesegnete
Weihnachtszeit bis dann
[Musik]
in einer Zeit die uns anstrengt und
frösteln lässt da die Krisen so gar
nicht enden wollen
öffnet Phoenix die Tür für Geschichten
die gut tun und uns berühren für große
und kleine Heldinnen sympathisch und
irgendwie unverwüstlich wir können nicht
zaubern doch wir können die Welt ein
kleines bisschen besser machen und
fragen was macht uns aus woher nehmen
wir neuen Mut das festtagsprogramm zeigt
das Leben von seiner schönsten Seite mit
den Dokumentationen zum Jahreswechsel ab
dem 19 Dezember bei Phoenix auch online
und in den Mediatheken von ARD und ZDF
Phönix der Tag
willkommen liebe Zuschauerinnen und
Zuschauer zu Phoenix der Tag und hier
drei der Themen heute die wir für die
Sendung ausgewählt haben
letzter EU-Gipfel des